je ne vis que pour les 400 mètres de
course
[Musique]
c'est juste écrit si bien c'est unis
fait sourd c'est du jamais vu
c'est vraiment fascinant j'espère en
faire partie longtemps
le casting est très éclectique chacun y
apporte son savoir
[Musique]
le plus important reste ce petit groupe
d'humains réunis autour de moi
quoi qu'il arrive
de beer
courir au mourir tu te rappelles salvet
dès lors les raccords rien à aucun
moment il s'approche d'une caisse
ne l'a jamais la faire
salo demi-fond milliards
la vie est belle c'est facile
je passe des choses
enfin bref qui ça change la tâche n'est
pas dans l'habitude j'ai dépassé les
attentes
chaque épisode iv nous et là c'est
vraiment du lourd
rangez le monde découvre le neuvième
chapitre à
la franchise fast and furious est unique
elle met en lumière le rôle des femmes
dans les films taxi mobile
c'est vrai que c'est correct
si autant de femmes qui déchire dans
fast lane
du vrai hockey milliard à l'aider
par ce fait main et fils a pris feu
elle relève la barre
tu viens le frein à main trésor
et surprennent
invaincu de la grande particularité de
faire cette période
dans ce film vie
on peut dire qu'on se lâche
quand il ya de l'action axa
fast and furious
pas montrer de quoi on est capable
vous serez pas déçu son cours
ouais
dubaï
[Musique]
qui roule à toute blinde comme un vrai
pilote de course doré dans ses piles ce
que je dis
on s'arracherait smalling
m
[Musique]
investissement
à nous de jouer
[Musique]
vous n'avez pas encore fait ça